[Music]
pft on yahoo sports peter king mike
florio top stories in the nfl top story
this week something called the super
bowl let's take a look at one angle
peter
under the radar players who could have a
big impact in the championship game
between the kansas city chiefs and the
tampa bay buccaneers give me
give me one that comes to mind to you
when we think of guys who currently are
under the radar and who may not be
come sunday night uh
i will take tyler johnson he's way under
the radar he's the
rookie fifth round receiver from
minnesota
that tom brady has gotten a huge amount
of trust in
late in the season he had that across
the body
sort of going the opposite direction a
huge catch against new orleans
uh in the divisional game and then in
the championship game
tyler johnson was the target of tom
brady and got interfered with obviously
in the famous was that really
interference play on kevin king of the
green bay packers
he's the guy who i think you look for
guys mike who late in the season
are engendering a lot of trust with
their teams
and for tampa bay it would be tyler
johnson to me
you know that's a great choice that
would have been my first one we first
became
aware of him with that incredible catch
he made on a third and 11
play in the nfc in the division around
against the saints
to keep a key drive alive when the score
was tied
20 to 20 and helped propel the
buccaneers
to victory uh you know a similar guy for
the
chiefs and with the chiefs look it's all
tyrae killing travis kelsey and a little
nicole hardman and every once in a while
some demarcus robinson
but byron pringle is a guy that just
kind of pops up from time to time not
that he makes a huge difference
but he's just around you know he's just
around
and if if the buccaneers are going to be
focused on taking away the name players
is going to be an opportunity for the
guy that no one's really paying
attention to to make a difference
i like that one and let me give you one
more for the chiefs
he may not be as under the radar anymore
but give me luxurious sneed
fourth round pick from louisiana tech
you know i picked one rookie for the
bucks let me pick one rookie for the
chiefs
legerius snead in my opinion has been
as impactful a guy in the postseason
for kansas city as tyron matthew has
they have used him to blitz to cover
to play the slot and to play outside
hugely valuable guy to kansas city
scheme
and one guy who's under the radar for
the chiefs especially as it relates to
jason pierre paul who didn't even know
who
he was is mike remmers the tackle that
pierre paul will be seeing
likely extensively on sunday remembers
is going to want to stay under the radar
that's the thing about offensive linemen
if you're not mentioning them that means
they're
doing their jobs peter
well mike he wasn't under the radar five
years ago was he against von miller
you know he's got a hope that it's not a
repeat of the past
yeah at least he has experience having a
long day on a super bowl hopefully for
him it won't be a long day should be a
great game though coming up in just a
few days
thanks for some of your time we'll see
you next time for more pft on yahoo
sports
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc
sports